we now have two more prominent
Democratic presidential candidates after
this weekend we have congresswoman Tulsi
Gabbard of Hawaii we have Julian Castro
former Secretary of HUD under Obama and
former mayor of San Antonio Texas
there are many identity games to be
played here Tulsi Gabbard the first
Hindu member of Congress would be the
first Hindu president she's the first
American Samoan member of Congress would
be the first Samoan president Julian
Castro could be the first Hispanic
President Wow okay I'm not going to be
playing any of those games in the
Democratic primary all right I'll talk
about identity politics actually on the
Friday show in audience questions but
I'm not going to be playing those games
I'm not saying identity is not relevant
but I am going to focus on policy at
this stage of the game I've said before
playing identity games or electability
games about who will Trump more
successfully be able to make fun of half
the country doesn't vote okay any good
candidate can win on turnout alone and
during the primary I'm gonna focus on
which candidates politics aligned with
mine period and we're going to start
today I'm not going to list a huge
laundry list of issues on which War
Elizabeth Warren Julian Castro and Tulsi
Gabbard agreed that doesn't make sense
we're gonna focus on the differences and
unfortunately with Julian Castro we're
still missing some of that key
information since he may not have
commented on all of these issues
publicly but what I can tell you is that
based on everything I knew before this
announcement about Tulsi Gabbard and
Julian Castro but more importantly after
doing deep dives into her politics over
the weekend which is much more on record
and Julian Castro
what I can tell you with certitude
today's I will not be supporting Tulsi
Gabbard / Elizabeth Warren okay from my
knowledge of Julian Castro's politics I
would be sort of choosing between Warren
and Castro with my initial impression
being that Castro is more of a sort of
centrist corporate type dem whereas
Elizabeth Warren at least in rhetoric is
more of a progressive Democrat but we're
going to get into that in more detail as
we learn more about Julian Castro's full
platform
far as tulsi gabbard and again I'm not
playing the identity games or
electability games I'm simply telling
you the policies of tulsi gabbard that
push me away and towards Elizabeth
Warren or maybe Julian Castro that's
what I'm going to get into today and for
people saying well why aren't you
talking about Richard oh Jetta I
interviewed Richard Oh Jetta who's a
West Virginia state Rep a couple of
weeks ago I am NOT going to be
supporting Richard Oh Jetta I did not
feel that he had a good understanding of
a lot of economic and tax policy during
our interview he started talking about
other Democrats as not being real
Democrats and I pointed out he voted for
Trump in 2016 I don't think that's a
good attack he's not my guy okay so at
this point I'm just going to talk about
Tulsi gabbard's position here number one
Tulsi gabbard's policy platform on
business regulation is reduce
regulations on corporations I don't
subscribe to the idea that a primary
pillar of improving our society will
come from reducing regulations on
business period okay Elizabeth Warren
wants to establish more oversight on
corporations that's a perspective that
is in line with my view so that is an
area I disagree with Tulsi Gabbard on
the foreign policy of Tulsi Gabbard is
extraordinarily concerning to me she has
appeared on Fox News to praise Vladimir
Putin and criticized Barack Obama's
foreign policy towards Putin which was a
sort of initial red flag Tulsi Gabbard
has praised Russian intervention in
Syria I'm against that okay an example
tweet from Tulsi Gabbard about that
issue says quote al Qaeda attacked us on
9/11 and must be defeated Obama won't
bomb them in Syria Putin did hashtag
never forget 9/11 I do not support
intervention in Syria to help Bashar
al-assad retain power period that's not
my politics Gabbard voted against
condemning the human rights abuses and
war crimes of Bashar al-assad's regime
that's not anything that I identify as
the left I can get behind that's the
sort of Leninist left
that I've sometimes referred to
elizabeth warren's position on that
issue on the other hand is President
Obama was right
to seek congressional approval she would
prefer us not be involved in Syria she
wants troops out but she understands
that The Situation's complex involving
the Kurds and many other factions and
it's important to know why Trump made
the decision to pull troops from Syria
when he made it I agree with that that's
basically my position I don't agree with
Tulsi gabbard's position on that issue
on gay marriage you might say well hold
on everybody all these candidates are
for gay marriage that's true Tulsi
Gabbard is currently for a gay marriage
like all the other candidates so far but
she used to be anti-gay she actually
called activists for gay marriage quote
homosexual extremists multiple times and
even though they've all arrived at what
are very similar positions today I would
still find relevant that she at any
point although good for her that she
changed her mind
used this language about people who said
hey we should be able to get married as
well Tulsi Gabbard also tweeted once
when we talk about conspiracies type
type stuff that Turkey is a supporter of
Isis that is simply not true and lastly
her political action committee Tulsi PAC
funds a lot of sort of centrist and more
right-wing Democrats over progressive
Democrats so the way that money is
allocated in that way is not in line
with my politics so what I'm saying Pat
is she's she's too far right for me okay
I don't support Assad defenders I don't
support people who dabble in unfounded
conspiracies
so for right now I'm with Elizabeth
Warren I'm gonna spend some more time
today researching Julian Castro and
we're going to go from there and you
know as well as I do Pat I'm gonna take
heat for this I'm going to take heat for
this because Tulsi Gabbard is popular in
certain circles of the left but it's
it's not it's not my politics what I
will say for now is it's great that the
three major presidential candidates
Elizabeth Warren Tulsi Gabbard and
Julian Castro they all support Medicare
for all and they're of course the first
three to announce their candidacy so
it's it's making the this
in the Democratic Party one that you
have to support Medicare for all to be
taken seriously will see if the other
candidates follow suit like if the
establishment types bite in even Hillary
Clinton if they decide to run we'll see
if they adopt that position too that's
very good and then from there we can
decide who is the most progressive who's
the best candidate but having that as a
starting point that's major absolutely
totally agree and we've been hoping
actually that Medicare for all
not a litmus test but just how can you
support the system we have or small
tweaks to it given its major failures
that doesn't sound very progressive last
thing I want to mention on this I'm not
going to be influenced by Tulsi Gabbard
having endorsed Bernie Sanders in 2016
okay last night when i was researching i
eated on my twitter account at d Pakman
what do you see as the primary
distinguishing factors between Warren
Castro and Gabbard and a bunch of people
told me Warren did endorsed Hillary did
not endorse Bernie Sanders played coy
waited around and then endorsed Hillary
a Castro just wasn't a big player in
2016 and Tulsi Gabbard endorsed Bernie
Sanders what about that I'm going to
evaluate Tulsi Gabbard based on her
positions okay I'm not going to be
swayed by the fact that in 2016
she liked Bernie Sanders the most that's
not really a factor for me at this point
in time because she now is running she
has her own positions notice I want to
go back to this I've said nothing about
electability I've said nothing about
identity stuff there are major
differences here in these candidates in
terms of who will actually be a player
in the 2020 Democratic primary just from
the three people I talked about today
I don't think all three of them are
going to be major players in the primary
but I'm not dealing with that right now
I'm focusing on policy and what's
knowable from public statements and that
is the way I am going to handle this
primary and I know that there are people
who are going to email me and say David
you should be considering things like
who can go toe-to-toe with Trump's
insult style who is actually going to
appeal to the amorphous
Western Democrats or the Southern Blue
Dog Democrat earn-out is 50% okay the
right candidate can defeat Donald Trump
and I'm going to focus on policy send me
your thoughts make sure you're following
the show on Instagram at David Pakman
show make sure you're following me at
David Pakman on Instagram we'll be
taking questions there about the 20/20
slate of candidates